La pregunta que muchos os estáis haciendo
estos días es:
¿Hasta qué punto China va a apoyar a Rusia
en la guerra de Ucrania?
Es, por así decirlo, una de las piezas que
faltan en este puzzle.
China es la mayor potencia que rivaliza con
Estados Unidos.
Teóricamente, si China apoyara decididamente
a Moscú, el balance de fuerzas podría cambiar
radicalmente.
Ahora bien, esta es la teoría, ¿ocurre lo
mismo con la realidad?
¿Hasta qué punto estaría China dispuesta
a involucrarse?
Pues, para responder a estas preguntas lo
primero de todo es resolver otra pregunta:
¿qué demonios piensa el gobierno chino sobre
la invasión de Ucrania?
Pues una cosa, la otra, que sí…
que no.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, por un lado,
China antes de la invasión llevaba tiempo
diciendo cosas como esta.
Mensajes que luego han ido repitiendo.
(Xi respalda la oposición de Putin a la expansión
de la OTAN en una cumbre que subraya lazos
más estrechos.
FT)
Y, además, durante las primeras horas de
la invasión también dijeron cosas como esta:
(Hemos declarado la posición principal de
China sobre la cuestión de Ucrania.
Hay un trasfondo histórico y un contexto
complejo en este asunto.
(...) El ministerio de defensa ruso dijo que
sus fuerzas armadas no van a llevar a cabo
ataques con misiles, aéreos o de artillería
en ciudades”.
- Hua Chunying, directora adjunta del Departamento
de Información del Ministerio de Relaciones
Exteriores de la República Popular China)
Ya sabéis: que es todo muy complicado, que
no van a atacar a civiles (en fin), que es
una operación limitada, que la abuela fuma…
Y así siguieron pasando los días, hasta
que:
(Invasión de Ucrania: China se abstiene de
votar en la resolución del Consejo de Seguridad
de la ONU para condenar a Rusia)
Y ya sabéis que hay silencios que resultan
atronadores.
La abstención de China debió ser toda una
sorpresa para el Kremlin,
[¿O tal vez no?]
El caso es que los chinos dejaron a los rusos
abandonados en la votación, contando el Kremlin
solo con el apoyo de Bielorrusia, Siria, Corea
del Norte y Eritrea.
[Menudo club]
Toda una puñalada para la supuesta historia
de amor que Xi Jinping y Vladimir Putin han
protagonizado en los últimos años.
Porque amigos, pocos líderes acumulan tantas
citas, los presidentes de Rusia y de China
se han visto las caras y frotado las manos
unas 40 veces.
Se dice, incluso, que para no aguarles la
fiesta a los chinos, Putin esperó a que terminaran
los Juegos Olímpicos de Beijing para empezar
la invasión.
Pero, ¿Por qué China no apoya a Rusia en
esta guerra?
¿Sacará Beijing provecho de esta situación?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes veamos un poco de historia.
T1(DESTINADOS A ENTENDERSE)
La Unión Soviética lideró al bloque comunista
durante la Guerra Fría.
En sus primeros años contó con el apoyo
del país más poblado del mundo: la China
de Mao.
Juntos estaban llamados a plantar cara al
sistema capitalista de Occidente.
Sin embargo, amigos, las relaciones entre
Moscú y Beijing se torcieron después de
la muerte de Stalin.
(Poco a poco, las disputas entre chinos y
soviéticos fueron cada vez más sonadas hasta
que en 1969 llegaron a producirse enfrentamientos
armados entre las tropas de ambos países
a lo largo de la frontera.
La frontera de más de 6.000 kilómetros entre
China y la Unión Soviética estuvo fuertemente
militarizada durante décadas.
La URSS mantuvo 44 divisiones desplegadas
hasta finales de los ochenta, 13 divisiones
más que en el frente occidental contra la
OTAN.)
Tras la caída de la URSS, Rusia y China mejoraron
bastante sus relaciones.
Impulsaron una serie de encuentros junto con
otros países de Asia Central.
Eran conocidos como los Cinco de Shanghai.
Su objetivo era definir claramente las fronteras
postsoviéticas, algo fundamental para reducir
las tropas desplegadas.
Con el tiempo estos encuentros se transformaron
en toda una organización internacional: la
Organización de Cooperación de Shanghai,
a la que en VisualPolitik ya dedicamos este
vídeo.
(Actualmente la OCS ha ampliado sus objetivos
y forma parte de la estrategia de China y
Rusia para construir organizaciones internacionales
al margen de las instituciones que diseñó
Estados Unidos al acabar la Segunda Guerra
Mundial.
De hecho, China y Rusia han intentado sacar
su propia alternativa al SWIFT.
Ahora que la mayoría de los bancos rusos
no pueden usar el SWIFT, es muy probable que
se pasen al CIPS que es un sistema creado
por China.)
¡Ojo!
No os equivoqueis.
El CIPS todavía está a años luz del clásico
SWIFT: ni siquiera compiten en la misma liga.
El SWIFT es el sistema utilizado por más
de 11.000 instituciones financieras de más
de 200 países diferentes.
Sin embargo, apenas 1200 instituciones de
solo 100 países usan el CIPS.
Además, hay muchas dudas de que este sistema
se pueda usar en Rusia sin problemas.
Atentos.
(El sistema de pago transfronterizo en yuanes
todavía depende de los bancos como nodos,
que pueden ser sancionados e influenciados
(…) Estados Unidos puede sancionar a estos
bancos.
– Chen Xin, profesor del Instituto Avanzado
de Finanzas de Shanghái)
2014 fue un punto de inflexión.
Cuando el Kremlin se anexionó Crimea, Occidente
castigó con sanciones a Rusia.
Desde entonces Putin se interesó más por
Oriente.
[Por cierto, un apunte: China hoy todavía
sigue sin reconocer la anexión rusa de Crimea.
Sorpresa.]
—
Pero regresando al terreno económico, pensadlo
bien: China aparentemente es un socio comercial
perfecto para Rusia.
China tiene tecnología pero le faltan recursos
naturales.
A Rusia le sobran los recursos pero no tienen
tecnología.
Blanco y en botella.
Desde 2014 el business entre Moscú y Beijing
no ha parado de crecer.
Los datos de 2021 hablan por sí solos.
(El comercio entre China y Rusia alcanza un
récord de más de 140.000 millones de dólares)
China se ha convertido en el mayor mercado
para las exportaciones rusas después de la
Unión Europea.
La mitad de lo que China le compra a Rusia
es petróleo crudo.
Pero también compran carbón, gas natural
y armas.
Por su parte, los rusos han mostrado mucho
interés por la tecnología china.
Por ejemplo, Huawei está llamada a jugar
un papel destacado en el desarrollo del 5G
en Rusia.
[Bueno, cuándo este llegue, quiero decir.
Porque hablando de Rusia dónde dicen 5G puede
que al final se trate de 2 y medio y megayates
en Chipre.
Ya me entendeis]
Pues bien, en este punto estaban las relaciones
entre estos dos países cuando Putin desató
su tormenta de fuego y destrucción sobre
Ucrania.
Y la pregunta es: ¿Cómo ha reaccionado Beijing
al ataque ruso?
Ahora mismo te lo contamos.
T2(LA GUERRA DE PUTIN)
En los últimos Juegos Olímpicos de Invierno,
China se impuso en el medallero en las competiciones
de gimnasia.
Ahora bien, os aseguro que la flexibilidad
de los diplomáticos del gigante asiático
no tiene nada que envidiar a la de sus gimnastas.
Los que seguís VisualPolitik habitualmente
seguro que habéis oído hablar de la Conferencia
de Seguridad de Munich.
Se celebra todos los años en febrero.
De hecho VisualPolitik participó en la de
2020.
Pero eso es otra historia.
El caso es que en la última Conferencia de
Munich, el 19 de febrero de 2022 para ser
exactos, participó por videoconferencia el
ministro de Exteriores chino, Wang Yi.
Y así de firme se mostró cuando le preguntaron
por las tensiones en la frontera de Ucrania.
Dejadme subrayar que esto fue apenas 5 días
antes de la invasión rusa.
Mirad.
¿Bien, no?
Se puede decir más alto, pero no más claro.
Lo que pasa es que es muy fácil ser tan contundente
cuando el statu quo se mantiene y todo está
más o menos tranquilo.
Pero claro, cuando de repente sale Putin en
la tele y dice que las tropas rusas se disponen
a cruzar la frontera, la cosa ya cambia.
Y como decimos en VisualPolitik, dicho y hecho.
Fue empezar la invasión y el Gobierno chino
comenzó a mostrarse incómodo.
Como que de repente tenía que buscar excusas
y justificaciones a lo que Putin estaba haciendo.
Es más, el mismo 24 de febrero, con la invasión
ya iniciada, la portavoz del Ministerio chino
de Exteriores, Hua Chunying, intentó hasta
convencernos de que la guerra de Ucrania ni
siquiera era una guerra.
El resto es historia.
Rusia ha usado la artillería y todos hemos
visto las imágenes de Jarkov y Mariupol devastadas
por los rusos.
Así que China empezó a moverse.
A moverse así, mirad ¿Véis?
Así, de perfil…
que no se les vea bien…
¿El problema?
El problema es que China pertenece al Consejo
de Seguridad de la ONU.
Y cuando el consejo de seguridad de la ONU
se reunió para pronunciarse sobre la invasión
de Ucrania, a China no le quedó más remedio
que votar.
¿Qué pensáis que votó China?
Pues hizo lo mismo que con la anexión de
Crimea.
Abstenerse y evitar criticar la actuación
de Putin.
Bueno, es que ni siquiera los medios de comunicación
oficiales chinos han hablado de invasión.
De hecho, el representante de China en la
ONU, Zhang Jun, acusó a la OTAN de causar
todos los problemas, ya sabéis la excusa
habitual de que la culpa de la agresión es
de todos menos de quien la lleva a cabo.
Pero, claro, ¿Qué otra cosa iba a decir China?
Porque esto tampoco supone un respaldo claro
para Moscú.
De hecho, desde entonces, China ha evitado
dar más pasos en falso.
Mantiene que no le gusta lo que está ocurriendo
en Ucrania, que defiende su integridad territorial
y que apuesta por resolver esta situación
mediante el diálogo.
Aún así sostiene que Rusia tiene sus razones
para actuar.
¿Que cómo se puede estar del lado del agresor
y del agredido?
Pues qué queréis que os diga, ¡No tengo
ni idea!
Supongo que será cosa de hacer malabares.
Lo que está claro es que China no gana nada
con esta guerra.
Incluso podríamos llegar a decir que le importa
más bien poco.
Esta guerra es la guerra de Putin y ni le
va ni le viene.
No van a quemar las naves ni por Rusia ni
por Ucrania.
Mucho menos después de haber visto cuál
ha sido la reacción de Occidente.
¡Suficientes problemas tienen ya en China
con la crisis inmobiliaria, la desaceleración
económica y sus relaciones exteriores como
para meterse en un berenjenal sin sentido!
Además, todos sabemos cuál es el principal
objetivo de China.
Y más viendo lo que pasó el pasado mes de
enero, algo que se viene repitiendo en los
últimos meses.
(China ordena la mayor incursión de aviones
de combate en la zona de defensa de Taiwán
desde octubre)
De hecho fueron muchos los analistas que se
preguntaron si Xi Jinping pensaba imitar a
Putin y aprovechar la ocasión para invadir
Taiwán.
Claro que, para el comunismo chino las dos
situaciones son muy diferentes.
Ucrania es un país soberano y reconocido
internacionalmente.
En cambio, Taiwan no está reconocido como
país soberano por casi ningún país: ni
siquiera Estados Unidos.
Y de hecho, poner en duda la soberanía de
Ucrania juega en contra de la propia China,
ya que validaría que otros pusieran en duda
la soberanía china en Taiwán que Pekín
tanto se empeña en defender.
Precisamente por eso, en Pekín parecen tener
claro que este no es el momento de China.
Eso sí, la guerra de Ucrania le está sirviendo
a Beijing de aprendizaje.
Está viendo cuáles son las armas que Occidente
está dispuesto a utilizar para frenar a una
potencia con armas atómicas.
De hecho, todo indica que ante una invasión
de Taiwán la oposición de Estados Unidos
sería aún mayor.
Taiwán es su noveno socio comercial más
grande y una superpotencia en semiconductores.
Además, unas hipotéticas sanciones para
frenar el comercio con Occidente serían letales
para la economía china, que aún depende
de las importaciones en unos cuantos sectores
estratégicos.
De hecho, y esto me parece una reflexión
importante: la batería de sanciones con las
que los Aliados no dejan de bombardear económicamente
a Moscú podría tener una lectura más que
interesante en términos militares para el
mundo y en especial para los propios chinos:
Si las nuevas guerras del futuro ya no se
libran sólo en el campo de batalla, quizás
no sea tan prioritario invertir más y más
y más en tratar de tener el ejército más
fuerte.
[Salvo si eres vecino de Putin, claro está]
Pero, no nos desviemos, todo esto no quiere
decir que los chinos no se estén planteando
como sacar tajada del tiro en el pie que se
ha pegado Putin.
Atentos.
T3( EL BOTÍN DE XI JINPING)
Una de las sanciones más importantes que
se han impuesto contra Rusia es la que actúa
sobre su Banco Central al congelar sus reservas
de divisas.
En esta línea, por cierto, China puede haber
tomado nota.
Evitar que en un futuro puedan castigarla
a ella es toda una lección de futuro.
Al fin y al cabo China es el país que tiene
las mayores reservas a nivel mundial.
Hablamos del equivalente a 3,22 billones de
dólares, aproximadamente.
Y en este caso la moneda estadounidense es
la predominante.
(El gobierno de Xi Jinping ha sido muy crítico
con las sanciones y no tiene por qué aplicarlas.
Pero, lo cierto, es que como mínimo, seguro
que actuará con mucha cautela antes de tomar
cualquier decisión que amenace su acceso
al sistema financiero internacional.
Si ya lo hizo con los suyos, cuando Estados
Unidos sancionó a algunos dirigentes de Hong
Kong, ¿Qué no hará con los rusos?
Y en lo que respecta al comercio tres cuartas
partes de lo mismo.
Porque por mucho que los intercambios con
Rusia batan récords, de momento apenas representan
una décima parte de su comercio combinado
con Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea.)
Entonces ¿qué podría querer China de Rusia
a cambio de su respaldo?
Si lo pensáis, tienen que ser cosas en las
que Beijing salga realmente muy beneficiada
en un momento en el que hacer tratos con Rusia
no está bien visto.
Por ejemplo, un campo que preocupa y mucho
a China es la seguridad alimentaria.
Antes de la guerra los precios mundiales de
los alimentos ya estaban en máximos de la
última década.
Ahora los expertos señalan que la invasión
de Ucrania amenaza el suministro mundial de
trigo
(China levanta restricciones a las importaciones
de trigo ruso)
Y por supuesto está el tema del gas.
Su consumo de gas natural se ha multiplicado
por 3 en la última década.
Y como la producción nacional no llega a
cubrir el 60% de su demanda, el resto lo tiene
que importar.
La mayor parte lo consigue mediante gas natural
licuado.
El problema del GNL es que es bastante más
caro que el gas que llega por gasoducto.
Y seguro que aquí muchos estaréis pensando.
Oye, ¿pero, acaso Rusia no es el gran suministrador
de gas a Europa?
Pues sí, pero actualmente Rusia apenas le
ofrece a China en torno al 15% del gas que
importa.
Claro que eso va a cambiar algo durante los
próximos años.
En 2019 entró en operación el gasoducto
Power of Siberia, que estará a pleno rendimiento
en 2025.
Además, en el último encuentro entre Putin
y Xi Jinping se cerró un acuerdo adicional
para suministrar gas a través de una nueva
ruta.
Y la invasión de Ucrania de momento no ha
cambiado esta tendencia.
Gazprom allana el camino hacia un nuevo acuerdo
de gas con China mientras las sanciones golpean
a Rusia)
Estamos hablando del nuevo mega-gasoducto
SOYUZ VOSTOK.
De completarse estos 3 proyectos, la capacidad
de exportación de Rusia hacía China se multiplicaría.
Esto abarataría las importaciones de gas
chinas y además incrementaría su seguridad
de suministro.
Además, dado el nuevo aislamiento ruso, seguro
que China puede arrancarle al Kremlin las
condiciones más favorables.
De hecho las sanciones impuestas sobre Rusia
nos llevan incluso a plantearnos la posibilidad
de que la relación entre Beijing y Moscú
se desequilibre aún más y el Kremlin se
vuelva muy dependiente de sus tratos con China.
Entonces será el momento en el que el régimen
de Xi Jinping pondrá en práctica una de
sus especialidades: la diplomacia sugar daddy
¿Qué es la diplomacia Sugar Daddy?
Os lo explicamos en anteriores vídeos de
VisualPolitik.
Lo hará cuando la posición de Rusia se haya
debilitado tanto que llegue a un punto en
el que el sugar daddy chino empiece a exigir
cosas a las que Rusia no podrá negarse.
Ahora bien, ¿realmente está China dispuesta
a rescatar a la economía rusa?
Pues ojo porque en un próximo vídeo, aquí
en VisualPolitik, os responderemos a esta
pregunta con todo lujo de detalles.
Así que no olvides suscribirte y darle a
la campanita.
Pero de momento, turno para ti: Qué papel
pensáis que debería desempeñar Xi Jinping
ante la Guerra de Ucrania?
¿Creéis que China en algún momento cambiará
su postura de apoyar simultáneamente las
demandas de Rusia y de Ucrania?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.